so reason there was a news for a metro
dancehall star sister Lisa Mercedes have
you wanna pronounce that trying to cover
up more after reverting to Islam stop
looking for cloudy fake he's new to the
religion what are you expecting she's
new you're not gonna expect immediate
changes
[Music]
my eyes my heart I can feeling an
unexplainable feeling being fun I said
ah Malik and welcome to a better care to
brothers and sisters indifference hope
you guys weren't shala so ok I'm ready
for iftar but I have to do this video
because it's very important and sadly
sadly once again the ignorance of our
young Muslim brothers and sisters
younger old is leaving other people to
take some of them to leave Islam and we
do not understand how severe this is now
the dancehall artist or even a reggae
version of value and holier so reason
there was a news of metro dancehall star
sister Lisa
Mercedes producer trying to cover up
more after reverting to Islam good right
that's good
so what do we have we have a sister
who's a dancehall artist and we know in
the dance world it's it's it can be
quite a bit quite crazy be it draws be
the music be it the way you dress up to
the way you dance you know it's it's
it's quite peak from what I know from my
days it wasn't [ __ ] to Islam so that
is all good now what the sister decided
to do was that she wanted to declare
that you need to understand she's from
Jamaica
she comes from a dancehall background
you do not expect new reverts to come
and instantly turn righteous yeah and
leave their bad habits it doesn't work
like that and if anybody's except
expecting for them to do that
you live in an ignorant let me give you
an important reminder she'll al-banna me
I'll have mercy on him he used to live
in Syria and he used to drive an
automatic a manual car man you car right
and weapons when you move this Audi to
Saudi Arabia to teach they gave him an
automatic car now when you go from
manual to automatic when what you keep
looking for the clutch right you keep
looking for the clutch so what shall
bandit would do is he would keep looking
for the cut and will keep pressing the
brake because it's automatic right it's
automatic here sorry guys
noise in the background yep guys cooking
so that's why may Allah bless inshallah
and all our wives and mothers cry
home assistance so moving on so he would
keep pressing the brake button thinking
is a clutch you need a clutch he came to
a realization he said subhanAllah
how long is it taking me to adjust to
this car and when we give advice to
people we ask for immediate changes look
at them look at the hikmah behind it
now this sister and like I said before
she did a track called Shahada car
member yet and obviously you need to
understand she does just a bit you know
I close it whatever it may be
she's new to the religion she's new to
the religion what are you expecting
she's new
you're not gonna expect immediate
changes now on the authority of abu work
ID and layfie radiyaallahu anhu who said
we went out to allah's messenger
sallallaahu was sent in the Battle of
her name it was a major battle Allah
mention this in in the battle in the
Quran Sura Tabo
I mean a battle of tabuk in surah tauba
and we had only recently left unbelief
and became muslims so they said we just
accepted islam so it's the talking about
started going to the battle of hunayn
polytheists the polytheists had a lot
truth where they would offer devotion
and they would hand their weapons hang
hand hang their weapons upon it so they
would go and hang their weapons for in
our blessing year we're gonna win in war
etc yeah they called it that and what
yeah so we passed by a lottery and said
o Messenger of Allah make for us at that
and what yet just as they have that on
what so a large message - lalalalala
Salim said the following so they think
the mushrikeen have this tree of you
know this law however I wanna make water
we have operations and make the one that
we have one now this can be a minor form
of [ __ ] yeah so the process of know his
reaction he said Allah who act by Allah
is the greater this that is the ways of
the people who came before you by he in
whose hand is my soul you have said just
as the children of Israel said to Musa
al-salaam
make for us a god just like their gods
so musa said indeed you are people who
are ignorant you should certainly follow
the ways of those who came before you
now this is a matter of [ __ ] or - [ __ ]
yeah
bear in mind in the narration says that
they were new Muslims now the process
enemy was harsh to the point but this is
talking about [ __ ] here let alone a
sister whose content is done from a
dancer a background profession and she
may still be doing that which she may
eventually leave so if this is watching
me listen my message to you please and
if there's any sisters watching this
please if you know that's why please
don't go to Instagram there might be
something appropriate pictures of our
sister so cuz she's new please send this
video to her sisters only not brothers
do not go sisters I'm entrusting this
review guys yeah now this is a new
sister and people have integrated her
she made a truck she didn't know right
and look at what people are seeing you
dumb
you ain't no Muslim doing takfeer doing
takfeer saying you're not a bit Muslim
and the process on them said if you
declare someone to be a disbeliever Eva
they are really the spinet if they are
not it can bounce back to you stop
looking for cloud you fake you are
Subhan Allah you are this is slander you
will get whipped in public in an Islamic
country a little surely you will get to
whipped slashed in public if she doesn't
forgive you for calling her a name that
she's somebody that sleeps around out of
Allah may you die a slow painful death
along with your family and look up this
filthy disgusting from the picture he
looks like an Asian guy I don't know
yeah he looks like I don't know you
black effing monkey you disgusting value
Japan alarm fosston
well I'm fasting I haven't brought my
fasteners I've still what time you
shameful man you shameful man you are a
Muslim calling her a black monkey you
you you disgusting man this is Islam
this is Islam you don't know the story
of when B'Elanna was code you son of a
black woman or something along those
lines and how the phosphorus sent him
his face changed and how angry he was
racism
you're carrying a Sunnah of Shaitan
Iblees you're carrying a Sunnah
shame on you shame on you shame on you
you dis custom person you are a
disgusting person calling her a black
monkey shame on you
well rahi when I saw her I was enraged
you should repent Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala how dare you calling somebody
else because they black monkey you
disgusting person
well like these kind of motions boy my
blood anyway and with other people in
the comment section f you you black next
one you are a big big big big
that's LUT I hope I hate you you're a
big look at this a new Muslim has come
to this town shame on you
is this how you treat them maybe they
don't know where is your hostel man
where is your assumption assume in the
best where is your good Dawa we're like
we discuss this sister or another soon a
hawk in mostly men corny must remember
that John any beliefs yeah I watch that
video learn something
subhanAllah shame on you guys what a B
might mayor my only wishes you die
strongly in hell this is a statement
from the system by the way my apologies
firstly I want to express my sincerest
apologies to anyone I've offended when I
made the video for Shahada it was done
with the best intentions we don't doubt
that sister and we know it was it was
intended to be a message to my phone's
about my journey and my newfound faith
while it has created some positive
conversations with people that want to
know about the religion there are some
people that equally are offended by it
this was never meant to cause any
offence to anyone out out of the utmost
respect I have decided to remove the
video look at her she acknowledged her
mistake
yeah she didn't know yeah can even one
say that's a sin she didn't know and she
took the video down out of respect if
she was out for cloud she just maybe
she's an and sister if you're watching
this we ask Allah subhana WA Ta'ala to
bless you and to guide myself and guide
you welcome to the religion of Islam
ignore these few
ignorant ignoramus says that they do not
represent our religion we want to say
may Allah bless in sha Allah if you
would like to get in
I can get my wife in contact with
yourself inshallah if you message me she
can tell you more about Dean if there's
anything that you wouldn't you want to
know and if there's other sisters
watching this send your message of
support to her only sisters because
obviously the sisters a domicile artist
and there might be some pictures that
brothers should not see so sisters only
please send your positive message to her
we want to welcome you to the religion
in Chelsea star please even all these
ignorant people giving you hate believe
me this is far for what islam teaches
when a new muslim comes to islam we do
not treat them like that we give them
some time some people say you don't need
to pray straight away if you can you
should but take time when I first came
to s not much talked about budget we're
gonna do two feet on me yeah we didn't
fit on me it's the struggle of people
different take it step at a time because
of people like you people run away from
Islam because of disgusting behavior and
those who are calling her a disbeliever
what an ignorant what ignorance and I'm
gonna finish with this hadith of the
Prophet SAW hollow cylinder in this
beautiful man from Adam the master of
Allah peace be upon him sent us in a
raiding party we we raided her al-qaeda
Bendre Hina in the morning and a cohort
of a man and he said there is no god but
Allah and la ilahe illallah I attacked
him with the spear
it was occurred to me and I talked about
it to the Prophet peace be upon him so
he killed a man even in the man said
Allah Allah Allah
yeah this is a osama bin zaid may love
mercy on him sorry it was a mistake he
made yeah he killed someone and we know
the punishment for killing a believer is
a V the mass of our talents towards the
process of a sermon I said that the
believers the believers soul life is
more dearer than the cabin so so he told
the peace be upon him about this and he
and the message of Allah peace be upon
him said did he profess there is no god
but Allah and even then even then you
still healed him and the message and I
said to mr. Allah he had a profession as
for fear of the weapon so he claimed la
la hey la la cause he was scared of the
weapon I was going to kill him he the
Prophet peace be upon him said did you
tear his heart open in order to find out
whether it has professor or not
so for those who have callin her
non-muslim did you open up her heart and
see if it was true or not huh did you
see it
how could you dare to judge at the time
of the Prophet peace be upon him there
wasn't one African when athletes and the
Prophet treated them as Muslims even
though he knew their work when ethics
pretending to be Muslim honorific is
someone who who utters it on the tongue
but when the heart is a disbeliever yet
he still treated them as Muslims and how
dare you because of something the
mistake she's done tell all your you're
a caffee almost not Muslim so Brahmin
says we can see from this that you
cannot judge and take people at the fold
of Islam based on they came acquitting
the worstest crimes yeah but that
doesn't take him at the fold of Islam so
guys that was in a nutshell a message
that I want to send to the sister please
share this video with her and for the
ignorant people who were messaging that
insulting her shame on you especially
that that one who was calling a black
monkey you disgusting person you should
be ashamed of yourself go repent allah
subhanho wa taala
what you did is more greater a bigger
sin a bigger sin then what the sister
did by mistake so panel or lady boils my
brother's racism this disgusting racism
and a lot of people still share it a lot
of people still how this raises him to
this day
may Allah subhana WA Ta'ala and that was
to purify ourself in this blessed month
till next time I'm sorry guys I was bit
annoyed what like really enrages me and
inshallah share this message with our
sister so next time I said I'm male from
what I mentor a better care to do not
forget to share check my video with this
righteous sister who instructed most in
length check that as well and also smart
agenda he's done a little video and this
is what which is very profound about put
o'clock and good Adam so next time I'm
gonna go eat some more later on what
happens right there head